so I just started using this website for
my MySpace profile called Snap layout.
comom let's see what MC Hammer thinks
about
it ah so what do I think about snap
layout well they saved my life let me
tell you why I used to spend three or
four hours when I would be spending
intimate
time clicking in friends one at a time
one at a time then my girl would look
over at me and she said baby
now I said not now I'm clicking my
friends in and 3 hours later I still be
clicking in friends and she would be
sleep and you know the rest of the story
but now boom one click my friends are
all added in and my life is changing I
miss the L man
again that's oh but what else no let's
not forget now your profile looks
amazing is that right okay do said we
can talk about the profile and how easy
it was to change the backgrounds and the
boxes and we got the colors right you
know I told him I wanted to be somewhere
between uh what was it slick and pimpish
you know so we had to get the colors
right you know and now if you take a
look at my profile you know it's hot
it's hot take a look at it snap layout
got it all right for me I'm happy about
it it's all fast fast I don't want to
you know make it like cheesy but it is
in a snap
baby uh so I guess you guys should go
check out snapl out.com right now I just
seen an MCM approved
all right approved by MCM
okay